[Music]
hey babe
hey babe hey babe
welcome to another episode of hey babe
how are you my friend i'm doing good you
look good you got a nice sweater on
yeah yeah i got this 70 off okay let me
tell you this story
this is from this company called g-star
raw i know g-star
i'm not trying to do any plugs here okay
no more with the goddamn plugs but right
my point is is that uh i don't
particularly shop there i think they
make some things i really like they have
some good codes good quality
right that's not necessarily my style
inadvertently
someone i work with a colleague of mine
that we exchange gifts
okay they they have given me a g-star
raw gift certificate for christmas
of the amount of five hundred dollars
look at me recently for the last five
christmases
okay now you have twenty five hundred
dollars worth of g-star raw
credit no not credit i used it yeah i
owned 2500
worth of materials in this home right
okay now
outside of those gift certificates i
spent zero dollars at g-star raw
right right right every year i go all
right
i don't know who got in their ear and
told them that i was the guy for g-star
raw
but the second year i was like peculiar
the third year i was like is this the
joke
the fourth year i was like interesting
yeah because it's really not displaying
effort unless this person thinks this is
really what i want yeah then it's
hats off yeah thank you for being solid
knowing what i want
fifth year in a row now here's another
thing g-star raw does that i don't
really like
on the gift certificate it says in one
year this has no value
and they say you can only use it at this
g-star raw location
that's ridiculous that was year one i
went into the g-star roll location i
said what is this and the guy goes yeah
that's how we do it here and i'm like i
don't understand like the customer from
the customer point of view
i got this as a gift you're telling me i
got to use it in 365 days then it goes
from
500 american dollars to zero right and i
can only use it in this store not online
and not in the other nine locations
they go yeah i go okay yeah it doesn't
make any sense to the store
it's like he had given it to me december
before that so
i was in there december of the next year
so i was days away
from the year one from the first 500
expiring
right so i walked in and i couldn't find
worth of stuff that i wanted so i said
to the guy well i don't understand so
if i don't just buy something right now
just to buy it
then you're gonna take this all away
from me and he goes yeah and i go okay
so then i have to buy stuff i don't want
right now and just return it
and then you give me store credit which
is good for how long and he says to me
we don't take returns and i said
what do you mean what i'm not kidding he
goes we do exchanges
not returns so if you buy something now
for the sake of it
i can give you a different size i can't
give you the product back and i said
that can't be right it even sounds
illegal and i
swear to you this is what this kid said
to me he goes
i go how do you get away with something
like that i
really was but i wasn't being mean he
goes uh
where'd she star raw and
our theory is you won't return it you
don't need to
we're that good that's a
horrible theory he's a [ __ ] answer so i
bought stuff that i didn't really
necessarily want
um and then fyi
it was december of the following year
so that week he i got a card after i
just exhausted the 500 oh
that week the next 500 and this pattern
because i always wait a full year
because i i don't go in there yeah
nothing else
the stuff that i have gotten has been
good and stuff like i get it like every
once a while i'll find something it's a
great sweater that doesn't look insane
on me
but like every year it happens so i go
in december
and i spend the 500 and then the week
that week it gives me the new 500.
and he has no idea that you have no
affiliation or even care about g-star
raw
in the slides no and i love the guy and
he gives he's a great gift giver he
gives me other gifts
and he gives me personal gifts he gives
me like things and he like he gives me a
book and he'll write in the book like
why he got it
like i love the man and and and and he's
a great man but it is funny that
two thousand five hundred dollars of
g-star raw i have gone in there with
gift certificates over the last five
years i'm not gonna say his name but i
think i know who the man
is really i i if i had to guess i just
can't you hey baby
go uh yeah so so but so
my point was this is a g star so get
this
here we are in december i got last
year's 500.
so i go in and i go into the city a trip
just for this
i got anxiety hanging over my head you
gotta understand when i get hit with the
a week after i spent the 500 which has
been the pattern for five years in a row
i then get a a burden is lifted when i
walk out of there and i'm like oh i got
myself a parka
right i got myself a hoodie right and
you know whatever and then it's like all
right now you're on the clock again
you got to spend this 500 at that
location at that location
and so then i go in and i go to location
this
like no joke like not even a month ago
and i
and it shuddered and i go oh my god it's
closed
and so i walk across the street into a
scotch and soda right not a nice line
yeah great line and uh they were closed
and i saw a guy named knock and i go
you're supposed to be open and he goes
the machines are down and i said well
all right but so now what he goes well
will you pay with a credit card i go
sure so he let me in and i said hey
fella do you know what's going on across
the street because i told him the whole
thing i told you he really
was he was a nice guy he listened and he
goes uh oh they're closed permanently
and i go oh i must i'll have to go to
the location he goes no no they're
closed permanently too
and i go wow he goes yeah they closed
all their locations
g-star raw has folded this is what he
told me the the
g-star raw yeah he says at least in the
new york area
every location new york city is closed
he goes you may be able to go online i
came home
i drafted us a firm letter an email an
electronic communication
and i wrote to g-star and i was like i
told him everything and they gave me a
code
to use 500 they're still doing online so
i took the 500
cold i went online this was 70 percent
off
7-0 it was listed at 140 and and i
bought it for 42 dollars
and wow it's a good second time i wore
it it's so and i'll tell you what it's a
hell of a fit
thanks and shindigo died so they do say
be careful because the garment
if you go on a light fabric so i'm also
they're giving me anxiety in different
ways now and g-star raw is one of those
things where it just fits it's good
i had an aunt who very similar to your
friend didn't know
didn't understand whatever you know when
i was you know maybe 15 years old
for about three christmases in a row no
gift cards or nothing
bought me opened up gift on christmas a
fubu sweatshirt
my aunt janet did that three years in a
row it was bought a fubu sweatshirt
a little white kid with blonde hair got
his hair cut at supercomputers for us by
us
four hours by his fubu sweatshirt that
she picked out does fubu have retail
themselves brick and mortar because i
always say fubu and like marshalls
yeah i don't know and the guy damon john
john shout out damon john jonathan
johnson one of my favorite trucks who's
yeah it was one of the favorite sharks
god bless fubu too
i'm saying when i see it it's usually in
the marshalls but i think that's where
you get like the
next season like the maybe the
irregularities you ever buy something a
regular
steep discounts on a regular and you'll
find them uh they used to be in the
outlet stores but now
you go to like a marshalls or a tj maxx
and you finally say i'll tell you a real
nice treat
something is has a steep discount okay
and because it's marked on the tag
irregularly they're transparent about
that
you say it says a compare ad i love to
go into marshalls and tj maxx and i love
to compare at
the receipt it says like you like this
uh candle motive it's not uh
it's uh it's eight dollars compare at
29.99
and then they let you know right there
the savings you're getting right there
right there right there
so what i do is i will go into um
to like a marshalls and you find
something irregular but you search the
garment up and down
and you can't even spot the irregular
right and then you bought it in a
regular
and at a regular price right uh that's
that's a fun little victory
see i'm one of those guys where i if i
could
if i could every single outfit of mine
i'd wear
a batting practice baseball jersey
because it hides my because i have an
irregular body
but you do have a good jersey body good
jersey body
when i take off my shirt it's a it's
just a letdown multiple women
in my life have either i've taken off my
shirt you know
right before i have sex and they've
turned the lights off
as soon as i took on my shirt or if
they've asked me to put my shirt back on
i swear to god oh my god no how do you
deal with that there's a girl on top of
me
for me i just wear a snow suit yeah and
i just i don't even
no there was a girl on top of me once
and i was go like she was until we were
having in the midst of it
and i was going to take my shirt off and
she put her hand on my chest and said
don't
i swear to god i swear oh my god
she goes down
[ __ ] what a terrible person or honest
honest i don't know that should give you
a dose like what how do you feel about
her
i mean well she stopped i'm literally
light-headed right now i'm spinning
around my head
we we had sex that one and only time as
you would imagine
don't she goes don't i was going to take
my shirt off in the heat of passion
okay let's let's let's talk about this
and i forgot what we got but
do you think that maybe she was just
like i can't even wait
like don't even bother no no we were
actively having sex and i went to take
it off because it was sweltering in my
room and she
she whispered don't and put her hands on
my chest just you have a wonderful build
no but i don't want crazy talk when i
take my shirt off i just i flabby tit
it's just weird like you don't and he at
the time you're a good clothes
box come on never went to that boxing
ring in in kentucky
that was within somebody's house yeah
well you looked up the guy who was like
the gus
a motto or domado whatever the hell yeah
yeah you looked up the guy who was like
he was like
i i don't even i don't know his name and
i forgot he was an older man
who ran a boxing a full boxing gym out
of his residential home
yeah that was also like a 200 year old
house
he was
it was something out of a movie i have i
have video we have video on photos i
have a video of you shout out like dude
remember he he got you on the bench yeah
here's what i did
i stayed because i was like all right
let's drive there together and maybe you
go in i'll go
because i'm not going to box you know
like and then we got up there and it was
like
the most unique unbelievable he he has
adopted adopted children
he takes care of cincinnati but this was
in kentucky i think it was in kentucky
we went into kentucky an old school
kentucky
boxing gym a house uh a ring in the
house that was there for 30 plus and
i stayed there for like like 80 minutes
just videoing you boxing it was yeah
yeah and then sal walks in and then sal
walks in and then
i heard one of the guys on the pads he
got one guy who says to the other guys
goes he goes yo i've seen that
[ __ ] before
and the guy goes yeah he was on best
week ever yeah that's what he said
yeah your boxes she said don't she said
don't
yeah she said don't so but you know
listen it's it's
you know and i've said this on many
podcasts i also had a casting director
uh you know nice guy who was actually
casting my cbs pilot
he said to me he said do you know what
your problem is
and i said no not that i asked for it
but i guess
what is it he goes you have leading man
face best friend body
so you're not castable either be one or
the other either be the leading man and
get ripped
or get fat and be the best friend and
you're hovering in no man's land i'm
hovering over and saying he said but
you're only out
is to create old thinking you create why
can't you be
the guy that you are i know that's why i
don't agree with that
well you know i know this man say his
name mark hirschfeld
wow you son mark zu push in here
mark if you're listening and we know you
are you nick lachey and a few hundred
priests are listening all the time
yeah lulu's listening saratoga we know
we know who our listeners are
no actually mark carson's a great guy
it's not mark hershfield that's another
guy i just
blanked on who it was so i said actually
one of the nicest men in casting
it was not mark hershfield i forgot the
counseling right and said that markers a
great guy
but for the point of the story let's
pick it up i'm just playing along too
now
if herschel didn't do it i'm not gonna
give him the business mark hershfeld was
one of the original casting directors of
seinfeld
and was telling me seinfeld casting
stories day one like with larry david
and jerry seinfeld while we were doing
my pilot wow like
unbelievable wow someone came to me a
couple of days ago who worked for comedy
central
and told me that your animated pilot
that they that was over there was
they thought and it was widely thought
at comedy central was one of the
funniest things like
they had ever seen and then it got it's
just the thing is that the network
changed hands and the new guy chris
mccarthy just said
they just can't that's what they told me
and the show was gone it's this is pr
i would say that's happened to me four
times yeah where the
the do you ever talk about my cbs pilot
i
know yeah but this is a true story yeah
the cbs that i had with chad's
commentary playing my father it was a
story about my life
in cbs we filmed the pilot the day that
they were the day
not the day before the day that you
picked cb les moonves at the time and
his executives
there's maybe nine pilots that's how it
works at these major networks
and they're gonna pick three or four les
moonves you know
there's less movies and then his the man
right on them was a man named glenn
geller
who was a champion of our show he just
liked our show he was at the pilot
taping
he liked our show oh he's weird it came
down they had picked three shows they
needed one more
it had come down to the one show who was
it going to be
glenn geller who was a champion who had
less moon vision he was directly under
command les moonves
personal hire had a heart attack the
morning that they were picking the shows
and was in surgery and no representation
we had no representation
and they picked another show that's the
way that's the way the cookie crumbles
and and and and this man today has he
ever called you an apologized
no nothing and he survived glenn
glenn geller great guy glenn we know
he's worth listening you know we know
you're listening you're the head of cbs
development les moonves is glenn and
glenn are listening right now
glenn pick a phone maybe you know what i
mean like we you know
he no one could have anticipated your
heart attack but also like
entered the dust settled he should be a
major network star right now
because because you have been laying on
margarine thick for a couple of decades
this man is not gonna realize his full
potential because you like
to fill every nook and cranny yeah with
i would like to ask you glenn
right now how selfish did you want to be
you didn't think about me at all you
just thought about yourself talking
about at the moment we're not talking
about the moment we're being reasonable
but after you were released make a
hospital and you see that you didn't get
slated
there's no like look i've made a lot of
i made a lot of unhealthy choices at
brunch
for a long time a long time and i didn't
know it would come to that
at that moment it was going to affect
chris's show right now i have a pilot at
true tv
that i've been told all all
signs point that it's going to get
picked up but i said i'm chrissy pilots
i've had
nine pilots wow not one of them has went
nine of them
so don't think well there's only
something that can happen
before we got jokers we had uh i think
four or five failed pilots
right so i mean and then who and i
you know you just never know i mean i
didn't i didn't know that anyone would
take to this show like this and and
beyond this
story didn't you like come you forgot
you had the pitch meeting or something
isn't that like a crazy story we had the
pitch meeting before we had an idea for
a show
and you were like coming with ideas on
the ferry or something yeah we had it
well
no what we do i'll tell you what we did
actually we had we had scheduled a round
of pitch meetings sometimes they call
them generals yeah but you want to go in
there with something
right just because i want the washington
generals who play the harlem
globetrotters absolutely not no no no no
i didn't get a bucket i didn't get a
bucket of sequins in my face
nobody hit a half court shot no not at
all but um no so we had these and we're
like
we don't just want to go in there and
not have anything so we said let's go to
lunch and think of a show
and uh oh think of anything i think of
any shows we and we went to royal crown
bakery
on staten island said some of the best
muffins i've ever had in my life shout
out to carmen
outside and we had a light lunch right
and uh we got i thought of the idea for
the show at the lunch
you thought of it actually we did yeah
all for you yeah and then um
we went with our cell phones that week
that i mean
two days later we went the four of us
only
with our cell phones and we shot like
five bits in like in and around times
square
cut the cell phone footage together
brought that and we first went to mtv
and they came back immediately i'm sorry
uh yeah they came back immediately
offering to buy it
but they wanted to make it a game show
that was on five days a week with a host
and the people that played against each
other were just contestants and we said
now we kind of want to be the recurring
characters that people get to know and
then they would root for us or not
and we want them to get to know us so
it's not just a game show we wanted
more than that and then we went uh true
a couple of days later
and uh they offered us to pick up the
show in the
in the room like no pilot like we're
going to give you eight episodes
uh no it's a pilot right but they
offered it in the room right and um
we got and they're going with them and
then we shot the pilot and they liked it
and uh
uh they ordered eight off the pilot and
then when we were filming the fourth
episode they said another eight
and they pushed it to sixteen and then
from then
we would have never ever i mean we had a
hundred ideas just like this
you know it's like i don't know yeah
clicks with people yeah just a throw
away like let's try it it was wow do you
have that cell phone footage did you
ever post that like the other do you
have it
it's not like the first tour we ever did
like eight nine years ago whatever
we showed it yeah we kind of did like a
little origin like this is this is what
we shot this is what became the show
that's insane and that was what 10 years
ago it was uh
the cell phone footage at that point it
was probably
early 2010. wow yeah that's crazy dude
it's wild
it's wild how [ __ ] like that just
happens like in life and
tv where it's like you have no idea that
like
what you're doing is gonna lead to like
a major thing like even
even life stuff like when i met
my kid's mom who would you know my girl
yeah
i i wasn't even gonna go to the bar
that like i wasn't even my friend pat
was like just come to bars like i don't
want to do it i don't there's no part of
me that wants to go to the bar he was
like
dude just come it's like literally
what's one drink is not going to change
your life
that's what he said you know wow yeah
i'll never forget that's why he varies
he said onedrick's not going to change
your life wow so then i go
meet her she's pregnant within a month
and i was like one drink it was a long
island iced tea unfortunately there's a
lot of outfits it changed my life
so i always think about that how it's
like you don't even know like you can
wake up one day
and like i know it's not like tragic or
deep but it's like you can wake up one
day like your life is gonna change in
that day and you have no idea
dude i mean prior to that you know i
have a degree in finance
i worked like st john staten island
that's right which by the way i drove
past st
john staten island the other day what a
gorgeous what neighborhood is that
yeah that's that times hill i mean some
of those some of the houses
that look there was like a gated
community it looked like malibu
yeah yeah what community is that wild up
there yeah it's unlike grimes
i don't know three four million yeah
it was pretty it's pretty nice over
there yeah but uh yeah that's what i
i mean i had that and then i and then i
worked like
at prudential right for like five years
and i was doing like not doing comedy at
all i was doing comedy but i was like
doing like sketch
improv and i actually was doing like
writing workshops and i did like some
open mics
and uh and uh you know i was just doing
it on the side
and then i left there and became a
bartender because i was like i don't
want to be here this is not what i'm
going to do
so i left and i was like bartending
flexible schedule i could do more comedy
and while i'm doing this i'll learn the
bar business right and save money and
then if
nothing happens maybe i'll i'll i'll buy
a bar and that's what i end up doing
yeah because you had that bar what was
it called cargo lounge
the cargo cafe cabinet then i but i
would work there and imagine then i went
to another place but like
my point was that like at one for like
eight years working there i worked off
the books with no health insurance
no medical insurance and i i was in a um
i lived for for 10 years in a uh studio
little basement studio apartment i think
i might have told you this
yeah like i didn't know i think i was
going to be there long so i never even
bought a mattress
so i slept on my couch for like nine and
a half years you slept on your couch for
nine and a half years didn't have a bed
yeah and no health insurance i mean
that's absolutely insane no health
insurance and worked off the books
nine years you didn't get them i was
like 33 years old
34 years old my first mattress was in
july july 1st 2010 my first mattress
that's just and i and and i took an old
one what kind of couch were you sleeping
on
it was like a leather um it's about this
length no it's longer than this
and you wonder why your feet face
different ways yeah that's true that's
true i mean
could you imagine not that's literally i
would imagine that's what isis is doing
to their
prisoners it's making them sleep on the
sofa like
at the time i moved out of there i had
slept on that thing nearly one third of
my life
you're a guy that told me too the most
important things you could ever do
is get a comfortable mattress and buy
good sneakers to spend money on because
of the percentage of the days that you
spend on your feet
and sleeping and yet you for nine and a
half years
well you didn't listen your own advice i
will say this if it was a problem
if it was problematic i probably would
have had to seek something else
but the couch was fine it's suffice to
find if you ever brought a lady over
what did you explain to them that you
have no mattress
yeah i kind of did you would just say i
don't have well for like i think a lot
because we're not talking about it
a big portion of it i was in a
relationship and then she had an
apartment
so she never slept over because there's
nothing once what i would do is
okay so this is what happened right so i
thought i'd be out right away
uh and and when i moved in there as a
gesture my dad got these couches for me
shout out to south dakota daddy and uh
and the couches were a three and then a
love c which is a two
yes and then a single yeah so he bought
the whole
raymore flanagan get up right and and uh
and it was a it was a living room it was
like i set it up like a living room but
there was no room for the bed
and um so when you know the girl i dated
you know was already like what if she
ever stayed over like
i i pushed the uh love seat
head on into this couch to make
a like a franken couch like this one was
like a good foot shorter than that one
right so i would lay on the long couch
and and then she would lay next to me on
the short couch
so okay because it sounds batshit
crazy to talk about it it is this is it
is sound this is
i'm talking no joke i moved into the
the the studio apartment in the year
2000 and i moved down the year 2010.
so i'm talking right now i'm talking 21
years ago
right that i was doing this but like i
it it it's it was fine like there was no
i don't have anything to you know i was
in a relationship long term
serious like it wasn't a thing like the
apartment was okay it was nice and
everything but it's like it was fine
it's yeah but i did that it's not that
way you see that you did that on a couch
in a studio apartment on staten island
yeah wow as a matter of fact we did a
pilot
we talked about failed pilots my first
pilot ever was a pilot
that fox and spike bit on with the guys
where we it was a single camera sitcom
we played like these exaggerated
versions of ourselves
and we shot the pilot presentation it
was like an origin story and we shot it
in that
apartment and i literally gave them a
tour and i showed them that this is
where i sleep
in the pilot do you have that footage
somewhere i do yes i do i'd like to see
that footage and the cell phone footage
guess where you can find it patreon.com
no fresh network you can't where we're
going to post it that's what that's what
i want to say on the patreon wagon
because patreon
is going to be a lot of fun all these
extra things that come
out of nowhere are going to go to the
patreon right to the patreon i mean can
you make a note of those i'll find those
patreon.com no pressure network if you
want to see that babe
it's just it's just it's you have a
fascinating
you're a fascinating character to me
in the sense of nine and a half year
because the amount of time i don't think
what people understand is nearly 10
years to do that
yeah is i was perfectly happy like
my rent was utilities included here's
listen to this
listen to this scam i had going yeah
okay i i lived there through four owners
of that home
four owners changed hands and i stayed
in the basement and they threw through
all every other
not one of the owners was like i'm not
i'm not so i befriended each owner
yeah because they have to negotiate the
deal with the old previous orders saying
the tenants say they say i got a guy
downstairs quiet as all
get out doesn't even have a bed pays his
dog pays his bills on
pays his bills on time you don't even
know he's there yeah and uh
and and i befriended and what i got was
so the i when i started there my rent
was 650 utilities included
in this in the summer i mean it's
ridiculous 650 you can lose included
and then when he left and the next guy
came he told him listen
the guy pays 600 because what
was customary is new guy takes over they
usually jack up about 50 bucks a month
and i would get back to where i was and
in essence the rent wouldn't go up
well p.s the next guy didn't raise it
and that happened again and again
so i was there ten years when i first
started day one my rent was 650
utilities included when my
when i exited it after 10 years my rent
was 500 utilities included oh my god i
didn't need to go anywhere
i didn't need to go anywhere 500 i was
going right into my pocket
that money wow the savings was
astronomical
i was able to buy a bar from it that's
literally you bought a bar you didn't
have a bed you bought a bar
yeah you bought a bar before you bought
a mattress that's right
i mean what other podcast does that
happen
yeah just i just like it was fine for me
you know no i don't think i
i'm not you it's a it's a beautiful
thing how content you are well
i don't get it like i don't know i don't
understand i have my car is like
well over a decade old right beautiful
car i don't care i got a car i
i i bought it i thought it was a little
too expensive to buy but i wanted to
pay off everything and not have any
payments and for like over six years now
i've had no payments
and i drive around this car and what i
was going through uh
security someplace and they were like oh
sal
and i'm like oh hey dude man the guy i
guess you know people talk and they
don't think they're just like
honest with you and he's like oh wow i
wouldn't imagine to be driving this
i was like well what'd you think he goes
ah some new really like expensive type
of car or whatever
and i was like yeah you know yeah i
don't need that or whatever and he's
like
yeah he goes i don't know why i said
that
i remember getting i don't know why i
just said that i was like it is what it
is
i remember i remember you and i
doing a gig last year i'm forgetting
where it was maybe it's with five and a
half hours upstairs i mean i did just
lease a new car but it was the first
but in ten years it was my twelve years
i remember getting into that car last
year we already had
the show and you already you know had
the amazing career and i remember
getting into the car and asking you is
this car going to make it to our gig
shakes when you get over 65. yeah yeah
but i loved it it was a great ride
i fell asleep i was like i can't believe
this is going to make it
but oh my god that was the time with a
really really
really real really bad storm yes you
fell asleep
i tried so hard to be honest
six hours in in what i would call el
nino
cubed yeah it was so bad that my wipers
couldn't keep up
for the six-hour drive yeah you stayed
up for like two hours and you don't i
don't know
look i knew once you're in the pilot
position yeah you just do what you need
to do
you were my responsibility at that point
yes and then you know
those i would do this for you i know and
i tell you right now i was driving that
night
i tell you right now dude i was white
knuckling that thing because another
thing was
it was raining so hard that i kept
hydroplaning everywhere
because the tires weren't like big
traction tires no
man while you were sleeping we swerved
around so much
that god was with us that night shout
out to all the priests
shout out to all the priests and then i
remember going into your hotel room the
next morning we got the conjoining hotel
rooms
and you at that point were were on
a very very very strict keto low carb
diet and you had ordered
you had ordered a full pizza i saw a
whole pizza box
i saw a whole pizza box and i said oh
sal you cheated and then i lifted up
the entire pizza was there he had
ordered pizza and ordered all the
toppings on the pizza and only in the
ate the toppings
off the pizza which i said this man has
skinned animals alive
i said this man is hey babe
serial killer yeah i couldn't believe it
and then i remember eating what i
finally committed
with no toppings who's skinning cats i
know who's getting cats now i told you i
killed the cat by accident once
no we here's the thing here's what i'm
gonna here's what's happened to me
i have no short-term memory whatsoever
yeah none you're like drew barrymore i i
is that
somebody's first date oh okay yeah i
love how
yeah i have i don't have it i don't know
in the
five episodes before this if i've told
this story no me neither i have no clue
none of us who cares we repeat them
guys what do you want me to do so i
remember the other day we were talking
and you said to me look me and i said
chris
how do i live a happier life i don't
remember that but continue
but i said to you yeah if you don't
remember because you were living a not
happy life
days ago i was in a fog so don't blame
you i didn't remember you weren't living
a happy life a few days ago
but what did i say to you when you said
how do i live a happier life where did i
tell you to go
told me to go to betterhelp.com and you
told me to put backslash hey babe right
get 10
off my first month what this is is it's
online counseling that's what you told
me right and did you take me up on the
offer
i did not but i plan to right is that
bad i mean i just been busy the last
couple days
no because i wanted to tell you that's
why i'm bringing it up to you i took it
up on myself because i said you know
what sal's not gonna do it
because he's not invested in getting in
happier life i know i am and i believe
in this
oh i i am and i believe in it and and
you know i don't have the time nor the
energy uh
to go out to uh to get get counseling
but plus i'm a loud talker but sal but
that's what i'm saying i'm always afraid
someone's gonna
hear me from the waiting room you know
what sal and that's why i'm happy to be
doing this and we have this all on
camera is you're not
a good you're not listening to me
because i told you sal as i've been
telling you as we've been friends for
years
you don't listen to me i told you that
betterhelp.com
hey babe is online counseling you don't
have to go out
you go the therapist comes on your
computer and if you put in the promo
code hey babe at betterhelphelp.com you
get 10
of your first month because you've been
telling me i have no money 10 that's
amazing that's like no tax and then some
yes yeah yeah i'm low on funds you're
low on funds i mean you know
i mean what are they gonna do i mean you
know i mean you don't get paid for the
stuff shifting to online now yes
yes shifting down online why should this
be any different
it's discreet yeah it's convenient it's
affordable it's probably more affordable
than other online services 100
it's more affordable than other online
services that i may or may not be on
that my father doesn't know about
but he does know about him my family's
very supportive of me being on
betterhelp.com and using the promo code
hey babe for getting 10 off my first
month because everyone wants to save a
little scratch here and there it's true
and it's better help
h-e-l-p i want a happy wife and a happy
life and i have a happy life
and if you've been thinking about it why
not take the leap there's nothing to
lose
try it because in in these times we all
could use a little
mental massage absolutely we could use a
mental massage or
or massage after hours but i if we want
to go mental we go mental the
betterhelp.com
hey babe so what happens you almost kill
the cat i was driving
down lindhurst avenue in rosebank toward
bayshore
bank yes i was in my plymouth reliant k
car which was the old driver's ed car
okay that i had bought for nine hundred
dollars while i was delivering pizza
and i called it old brown and i had my
girlfriend this was like high school
like like just right at high school and
i had my girlfriend in the car and my
sister who's 10 years younger than me
and we were going to polymer video on
bay street to rent a vhs
still there palmer video long gone now
it's a vet imagine a video store was
still there it's actually a vet which is
kind of ironic to this story because we
were going
to the video store which is now that it
wasn't then and as i was driving
down that block at a moderate pace mind
you not speeding right
a cat ran in front of my car and i
slammed on the brakes and i hit the cat
and killed the kids and i was like oh
and
let me tell you something right now i
don't have a strong constitution
yeah i cry at commercials yeah i've
never killed i'm an animal lover
yeah i remind you i don't like cats but
like i don't want to kill a cat no no i
don't tell me the the unthinkable
happened i went to something
and i looked in the thing and i saw it
in the street like and i'm sorry this is
graphic
it's a fine story it ends up okay i
pulled over
i was in shock and i get out and i was
going toward the cat and there were
people sitting outside on their front
like like
porches and lawns and a couple of people
came over
and they were like oh my god you hit the
neighborhood stray
he's blind and i look at the cat and the
cat
has no eye in one and a [ __ ] a
completely messed up eye on the other
like the socket has no eye in it
oh my god the other one has like it's
just all jacked
yeah and they go it's not your fault the
cat's blind don't don't feel bad
and i go i i don't know what to do i
cannot leave this cat here i go i have
to go to a vet with this cat
so they put um someone went and got a
box a brown box and a shovel and a
blanket
and they lit we lifted the cat we put
the cat in the box wrapped in a blanket
oh
wait so you you put your hands on this
cat blind
i didn't but the na the guy in that who
brought out the blanket the lady brought
the blanket in the box
they put it in the box for me they knew
the cat they used to feed it
okay like it's our neighborhood cat we
all feed it it's dripping and blood this
thing
it wasn't bleeding right but
inside the fur had to be like things
shifting around right
yeah you know and so i
went to another animal hospital like a
couple of miles away
okay and i walked in and i said pimp
just googled cats with no eyes there
there they are that's what
that's what the son of a [ __ ] looked
like yeah yeah okay comes up
and i walked into the i walked into the
vet and i said excuse me
uh which was which which is the event at
the time no no this is another vet but
right now the place i was going to rent
a video
is a vet now yeah but i i drove was it
was again prime heart video what was it
palmer palmer video arnold palmer arnold
palmer
so uh i go and i walk in and i say hello
the car in front of me
the car in front of me i was driving
behind it uh hit this cat and kept going
yeah i can't you know being the person i
am i can't
have that yeah i was young i was scared
i didn't really know what the protocol
was right i never
hit anything so i just didn't want i
didn't know if he was going to report me
yeah i didn't know if they were going to
be like
you owe us 25 000 i don't know what was
going to go on right so
he goes and the doctor like didn't buy
it the vet didn't buy it from the second
he's like
oh yeah it happens and i was like yeah
and he goes uh he goes
so yeah this we got to put him down and
i was like oh my god i'm so sorry you're
like i'm so sad
and i go wow and he goes yeah so we
incur this cost
and i was like yeah yeah and he goes so
if you want to put something toward it
it would be appreciated
and i was like yeah i was like man i
wish that car
that was in front of me stopped because
it's so wrong that yeah that he's not
gonna contribute to this
right and uh he was like yeah and he
just kind of like
meanwhile there's whiskers coming out of
the front of your car
yeah there's a buck you got it on the
g-star raw sweater
and didn't you just say that you love
animals and you don't want to kill
anything and then live on camera you
killed that thing i don't care i'll kill
a nat i'll kill it now i'll kill
that's family i'll kill i i'll kill
that's in it i don't know what
ecological
uh effect that'll have on the world and
by the way i gotta remember to put the
mic up to my mouth
it's okay but i'll kill i'll kill every
single night and then worry about it
later you don't think about it you'll
step on a road you'll kill a roach
that's gonna be dead in a in a in a day
anyway isn't it
i don't know what's this it was spanish
you better get
square one main trait wasn't annoyance
right i would be fine with it i'd be
like fly around
do your thing actually was flying out of
your beard
you look like it came out of your beard
it's very by the way i got to be honest
with you sal
it landed in there and i slapped your
hair this is the look that i hope
you always keep is that right i was
trying to grow my hair out for
three weeks as soon as it touched my ear
i cut my hair
oh you like this i wanted to grow my
hair just like you like a long time
to grow at the end my last well i've
gotten two haircuts in nine months
right uh so you went here like this like
that
uh in you know in march march you had
you had a regular haircut
i had this hair in my life before i like
the back i've had hair and i i will
mark it down i'll give you the i'll give
you the picture i had hair
ready it was three times this length
college college i look like grunge it
was like
to your shoulders what and you put up in
a ponytail yes
hit me in the top tip would you put up
in the top ten here yeah good tapped in
hair
yeah tth and i i used to shave
underneath though i didn't have this
that's cool it looks awesome like this
it's nice really it's curly and flowy
yeah
you know what it is we have to keep the
same haircut for the show so the show's
on
i can't be on one scene like that and
once like this but then at the
quarantine
all bets are wrong i said i'm gonna go
on do not look at the tv how do you
spell nat
gnat wow you knew that there was a g a
lot of people don't know that yeah
i would i was thinking right in the head
i was thinking that oh
yeah na8 nat i don't know what that is
or where that g comes from
ganette yeah good gnu gary the canoe
isn't that gnu something too
there's no good news like good good news
gary i'm showing my age
showing my age i don't know uh so anyway
he says to me
he says yeah i go yeah i wish that guy
would have stopped and he goes
yeah and then it was silence it was
almost like a larry dave like a curb
moment where they go
where they look at each other like when
he's like dude
look at each other like that he kind of
did that to me and then i reached to my
wallet
and i remember it was the year i first
got i'll tell you what year it was it
was 1995
because it was the it was my second
credit card i ever got it was a discover
card
okay and my first one was 94. my shout
out discover card
that came up online oh there you go
there's one on me on the right with the
long hair i mean how old were you there
uh i was uh let's let's think about this
real quick
i was uh i posted this on the patreon 19
19 years old
very very chiseled chiseled chin and
beautiful long hair
you look like a you look like a lesbian
yeah i did look like a lesbian
right you look like a beautiful lesbian
yeah actual beautiful beautiful girl
yeah i actually i mean gorgeous
gorgeous feel much different than a
beautiful lesbian either
yeah that's me and that's me when i was
15.
you mer and joe yeah wow
crazy right that just comes up that's me
in high school
i wonder where they found that i'm sure
at one time or another people i don't
know who knows
no idea where q was in that so i reach
in i pull out my discover card by the
way still have it
joe remember since 95. in this picture
that that we have up and we can post
this picture
joe gotta look he looks like a black man
from the 60s
that's what he looks like a black man in
nineteen twenty feel like
that's what with his hair that he looks
like that he did have very coarse hair
yeah yeah yeah great
so great yeah so he says he goes how
much i go i got do you take discover he
says yeah
because he goes uh how much do you want
me to put on here and i go um
25 yeah i mean that was i mean i was
18 right and uh he he rang it up 25
bucks
and then put the cat to sleep and then
gave me
a death certificate with it was a
receipt slash death certificate for the
cat
and and he and it's like an official one
and he wrote on this day of blah blah
and then it wrote like
it was in there like cat's name like it
was blank like a mad lib right
and he just wrote stray wow yeah
do you have that stuff i do oh my god if
you don't go to patreon.com
i mean the amount of things you're
missing are epic i know i haven't i've
seen it i know i would never throw it
out i will find it i don't know when
that'll be up on the paint
okay okay that's freaking interesting
man yeah
i yeah i i'm not i just i don't
necessarily
love animals i think i've told stories i
i had a dalmatian cruella
did i ever tell you about cruella no i
didn't know yeah so i had a dalmatian
cruella
who i liked but was scared of [ __ ] i
grew up with i grew up but well not
really we had it for about six months
because
the main thing was don't let her go into
the basement but how old were you
11. okay and she had bitten like she had
chewed up my last my like a
pair of sneakers that my grandpa just
bought so you can't leave her into the
basement i never knew why my mom was
like no
she's never allowed to go in the
basement i said okay so then is there a
chocolate factory
i had no idea well worse she she
uh she pissed me off or whatever or i
just didn't like dogs or i was just
being a dumb little kid
and i let her go in the basement and
hours went by and the dog never came up
she had gotten down into the basement
eating all the clorox and died on the
basement floor
that's one story the second story i
swear
yeah i mean
i never knew this about you yes not
uncommon you do this to me a lot
but i sat here going crazy that i hit a
blind cat
feeling the guilt for it and you don't
mention that you basically
poisoned your own dog it was your own
dog my own talk
clorox clorox it was accidental right
but it happened
wow so we've both killed an animal act
yeah
i guess inadvertently then
then my aunt had a uh a pet bunny rabbit
named annabelle
had a yeah had had a pet bunny rabbit
named
annabelle and you're like lenny from of
mice and men
yeah so annabelle so this is just what
happened and my uncle shout out uncle
victor r.i.p uncle victor great guy
right from the motherland of puerto rico
just a fantastic guy
he annabelle dies one morning i'm going
to school he would walk me to school
sometimes
i'll never forget my mother had just
given me a sandwich
i have a brown paper bag you know
uh with my lunch i'm walking down the
stairs my uncle says please hold on
annabelle died takes he doesn't
he doesn't have a bag or anything that i
have the lunch bag dumps my lunch out
puts out i'm not like puts annabelle the
dead rabbit in a bag
in like a brown brown with half its tail
still sticking out
was go the plan was to walk to go to the
supermar or the store on the corner to
get a plastic bag
wrap it up and we were going to bring it
to a vet he sees the garbage truck
coming down the block
and throws annabelle the dead rabbit
into the garbage truck
right in front of me i hear the thing
the garbage men don't see it's just more
garbage in the truck they don't know
it's a dead rabbit
i hear it coming down and i hear like uh
what i thought was bones
crushing bones crushing onto the back of
the garbage truck
and i walked into school holding a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich in a
ziploc bag a bag of carrots
and a little thing of milk and my sister
seraphine rip sister seraphine the
principal of the school same with that
square win
says why is there no lunch bag i said
cause uncle victor put out
[Laughter]
that was that's when you want to hear
that
i was i was spiraling into depression
yeah
that gaseous baseline just pulled me up
from the ashes
yeah right there that smart sound by the
way is one of those farts
isn't that real that's a real story it's
like
like your ass is like chocolate can we
hit it again
yeah so this fart just over here yeah
[ __ ] is charles man
i remember it ricocheting and there was
like a breeze
that hit the back of my ball sack
because of the angle it went
it kind of shut up that way
[Laughter]
you hear the reverberation it sounds
like i'm turning on an old car
it sounds like the beginning to the
theme song for what's happening
it's like
what's happening
and then hear the fart so that's that
listen to this the mother on this sitcom
was name was mabel king
she lived in a building called the
continental towers which is like an
affluent residential building in
manhattan when my dad was young one of
his first jobs ever he was the doorman
she had a crush on him wrote him a note
that he kept that i read when i was
little he used to be on the wall in his
office and said to my
lovely darling sal i love you so much my
sweetie pie love maple king
wow yup so mabel king could have been
with nelson
hey hey hey shirley two grapes hey hey
hey yes you don't know that you ever
know i've just never seen the show
rerun
is that yeah rerun dance okay yeah no i
think shirley i gotta watch the show
oh it's great it's like good times era
you know
maybe even it's actually after good
times i think yeah
he i mean he's he has a he's famous for
it the rerun dance yeah
he gets down right he gets down look
oh my god this guy's awesome
[Laughter]
here's what i want i want you to i want
us to learn that dance choreographed
thousand percent uh on the patreon
patreon.com like some of these things
are not going to be delivered yeah but
like if we could learn that dance
together
would both be rerun for halloween and we
just go in there and do it
here's what i want to issue though a
challenge to our listeners
i want to have annabelle uh the deceased
rabbit i want to do a comic strip about
what might have happened if she came
back to life
out of the truck i'd love to do that
maybe she ate something like it was like
a superhero story she ate something that
was
slightly toxic and it gave her and then
she was reanimated
yeah maybe we do a little comic strip of
annabelle the formerly deceased rabbit
right and the adventures of that of that
rabbit did i ever tell you the story
about the the house party about the
recently deceased rabbit
maybe our mascot annabelle the recently
deceased rabbit is the mascot yeah
yeah you know what i mean i like it yeah
because it's giving new life right to to
her and her story
right and about the recently deceased
rapper i like it
yeah so so there's that and then i we
would talk
i need someone because there was
something i wanted to talk about before
and i can't
i just can't remember oh yes
did i ever tell you about i've told you
about that dead dog at the house party
did i ever tell you that one unclear at
this moment the house party dead dog
thing
with my cannon okay so this is
i think you did tell me this and this is
did we say this on the podcast right now
no no but
is this something that was it's crazy a
crazy story i know this story i know
this story
crazy story we have never talked about
this on the podcast because when you
told me this
i think we were in motion and i almost
ejected my own body out of the car
i swear to god what you're about to say
is one of the most crazy stories i've
ever heard in my life
house party with mike cannon i'm gonna
turn the air back on keep talking yeah
yeah
yeah yeah okay so there's a house party
with mike cannon
so they have this party
okay they have this party you know 16 17
year old kids
the parents are away the parents are
away
they're not in the house they're
supposed to be gone for three days
whatever it is
so like many kids have a house party so
like kids kids just start having a house
party they're teenagers whatever they're
drinking they're smoking weed
okay so as many kids would do this
the the kid puts beer in the dog's bowl
and the dog starts drinking beer and
they're laughing because the dog's
getting drunk
then they start smoking weed and they
start they start hot boxing
the dog with wheat so they're getting
the they're getting the dog
drunk and high yeah okay they do this
for
have you heard this story well there's
only one
there's only one time that you can hear
for the first time
okay i'm telling you okay so they do so
they're hot boxing
this dog and
they are giving it beer and they're
having a great time going off they're
having a great time
the dog falls asleep and they're like oh
the dog's drunk passed out it got high
got drunk whatever
next morning comes around the dog's dead
the dog is dead unfortunately the dog is
dead
everybody has ding dong the dog is dead
ding dong the dog is dead
everybody has left the party the kid
wakes up drunk hung over the dog's dead
has no idea what to do with that as he's
realizing this panic setting in
his parents come home early from where
they were going
he now realizes i've thrown a house
party
i've killed the family dog my dad is
walking into the house and my mom are
walking into the house
so what he does is he waits for them to
come and he takes the dead dog's body
out the back door rests it up against a
tree
runs up back into the house and says dad
give me your car keys
give me your car keys i forgot i have to
go get milk or something
takes the car and backs it up
into the dog into the dead dog takes the
dead dog that he had previously placed
next to a tree he placed it next to the
tree runs up
gets the keys backs it up twice
into the dog uh into the dog
long past dogs for 12 hours yeah
runs back in it says oh my slits and
marijuana
runs in says oh my god dad i just killed
the dog
he goes you're immediately going to
military school
i watched you carry the dog put it up
against the tree
and back up into it twice get out of my
house
you're going to military school that's
the last straw and then he went to
military school for two years
that's a true story that is in the
father is
watching him re-kill the dog
twice and then lie about it and then lie
back he watched him carry the lifeless
body of the dog place it
back it up into it and this gentleman
now at the the time being yet to that
subsequently
his penance was to defend our country
yes
he was like you're going to defend the
united states now that's what you're
going to do you're going to fight iraq
it's it's it's it's it's life no liberty
and no pursuit of happiness it's just
the life yeah and then recently
you know of course upsetting my my
family dog
died natural causes you know uh uh well
had to be put down i should say i had to
be put down
and i'm in there you know i was very
upset it's horrible you know whatever
um uh you know comforting it's you know
bad for me whatever 15 years i'm the dog
love the dog shout out larry um he's
definitely the gay part of having right
now he's definitely gay dog loved him
god bless him he you know he's still
alive
and they are they i got to talk so he's
alive you know he's
you know he's on his way out and they
put in the needle and they said this is
going to be painless
they're going to inject the the thing to
kill him whatever that is and it's going
to be painless he'll be dead and
he'll he'll just pass he'll just pass
quietly in the next 10 seconds
so they inject they quietly and 10
seconds to me are red flags yes
so they inject so they inject this
substance into him and we're waiting and
my mom's crying and breathing heavy and
that everyone's rubbing her back
and larry's still just looking at us
blinking
and we're saying it's going to happen
any second
so i say it's like cape canaveral so my
mom is just going
and then and then and then the doctor
says i swear after about sensitive
doctors sometimes it can be 20.
i swear the doctor's like don't yeah
so the doctor said sometimes it could be
20 seconds and
he's going to pass it's just double this
it's just gonna be like it's just gonna
be like he's going into a dream
uh to a light sleep
larry's just literally looking
dead
yeah yeah listening to us so
now we're coming pictures of larry and
annabelle i want to see the comics
that's what it is if you're an animator
out there please make sure
so now it's upwards of 45 seconds and
larry's still just looking at us so then
my mother says what is going on
what's going on so then the the vet says
just just give it
give it another moment she goes she goes
i'll be right back
she comes back in maybe 20 seconds later
she goes i apologize
she said my assistant is new here the
dog next door was dehydrated we gave
larry electrolytes
the vet says the vet says over the next
few minutes you may see
a little surge of energy
so please
i swear to god
[Music]
she goes larry's like i'm gonna
because you know just put in his pawn
they injected
with the wrong thing and then she goes
so you may over the next few minutes
see he may all have had a center burst
energy she says she goes pay it no mind
because last hour is here and then
he gets a burst
yeah yeah so i'm like rubbing the back
whatever
and then finally they come in with the
right stuff and then the the
that says to my most crumbling she goes
i promise you mrs
i promise you i promise you this
substance will kill him instantly
and i was like my mom is like
head
i promise you once he's done being
replenished
we will knock him back down to size once
he's done doing a couple of laps around
you know acting like a puppy it's all
fake we will kill the thing that you've
loved the motion
this is important now we injected him
with something to make him youthful like
when you first met him
yeah it's smoking mirrors yeah just know
that electrolytes
have a shelf life of 56 seconds yeah
he's going to die he's going to die hard
the way you want the way you want him
so finally that you know kills him
horrible you know horrible man i was
like i can't believe i went through that
ordeal i'm like i know whatever
they cremate him my mom's waiting for
the urn
for the cremation they said they would
mail it out overnight it it will be
there within 48 hours
we accidentally three days go by
three days four days five days no idea
where it is
they mailed the urn to the wrong address
wow
so they mailed it to the wrong address
oh my god
and finally we got it this was the
dalmatian this was no no this was the
dachshund
oh my god dude yeah yeah so that's i
don't mean to laugh but that's the
funniest thing i've ever heard in my
life
i mean that's just i mean you're trying
to kill a dog you give him electrolytes
yeah he gave him electrolytes because
the dog next door was dehydrated
so imagine they would have brought and
they killed the other dog
right she goes my assistant's new here
you know
it's a learning curve wow i should say
yeah he's just silent just blinking at
him he keeps looking at us he doesn't
she's like any i remember she said
sometimes it's 20.
[Laughter]
because you're trying to be peaceful and
somber thoughts and prayers don't
suppress so
that she's like holy she's like look at
annie
should be any second now just he's gonna
drift off
from where she came visit his parents
i've never really seen it gone this long
but just believe me he will pass
and three two
[Music]
may have given the dog luckily
[Laughter]
yeah it was like literally i mean he
just kept blinking and looking up at us
my first dog i ever had uh house called
to put it down
and uh i was so young and i didn't have
enough
i wasn't the one in charge right and i
remember being really sad they put it
down in the yard that i lived in my
grandpa's house i lived downstairs
they put it down the yard and i was
there and i was like talking to her
and i you know it happened and it was my
first one that i ever lost like that i
was super sad
and i was just like you know what
happens now i didn't want to let it go
right and i swear to christ dude
the doctor she had one female assistant
with him and it was the doctor they
pulled up in his own car it was like
camry they came in the back in the yard
they put the dog down
10 seconds after the dog went down he
reached into a bag pulled out
hefty bit a black hefty bag went
and ripped it open threw the dog in the
bag picked the garbage a black garbage
makeup
with the dead weight of the dog in it
walking down the side of my
grandfather's house
down the steps onto the block i was
walking with them because i was like
can i say something this doesn't feel
right he popped open his trunk
threw the dog in the trunk in the black
orange break closed it
they were like all right you know we'll
send you the bill you know we'll send
you what you need and they got in the
car and they just drove away and i was
like
i cannot believe that this guy just
that's what it is there was no bedside
manner there was no protocol there was
no like there was no like tact
no no it was just like this what we're
gonna do i know we've mentioned him
three times on the on the podcast oh
my canon should follow the great mike
cannon at my account on instagram
he's had multiple cats that have died in
his house and he buries them in his
backyard by himself
i will tell you we had three dogs when i
looked at my grandparents one was a
chihuahua
and when that dog died they didn't tell
me for weeks they said it was in the
hospital getting better because they
didn't want to break the news to me
i later found out my grandfather buried
it in the yard right in the yard yeah
on that no yeah by the way it's illegal
it's legal to bury an animal on private
property illegally burying animal on
public property
including parks so don't get in good
luck with that yeah i mean sure
i mean i i got news for you right now if
one day i get a dog and i have property
that dog is going in my in my yard i'm
gonna kill you okay come
yeah all right well listen you know i
know i i mean there's definitely like
every other episode there's definitely a
couple of things we didn't get back to
right i wanted to [ __ ] on staten island
real estate like you can't imagine but i
but just because i want to live on
staten island and the people that i am
trying to buy the house from will not
give me the house even though i'm giving
a full price offer
and and and and as much money down as i
can possibly spend well let's let's do
it next episode
next step is your venting episode
we've been trying to get it done for a
few episodes already so just let it go
let it
fly from the beginning yeah uh but the
important thing is annabelle the
recently deceased
rabbit i think is in is the is the
mascot now yes
possible possible visitations from stray
yes
in the comic strip you might see stray
the blind cat yeah and you might see
you might see uh uh uh uh who's the
clorox dog
clorox dog or you might see larry
larry i mean these are we're building a
universe of characters for this comic
strip
but but but but let it be known
annabelle the recently deceased
rabbit is who i i want to breathe new
life into and i'm and i and i agree with
that so
there you go this was hey babe hey babe
hey babe
hey babe hey babe